le procès jusqu'à mercredi aux assises
d'indre-et-loire d'un déferlement de
violence celui commis par cet ancien
étudiant ivoirien 22 ans à l'époque
accusée d'avoir asséné 28 coups de
couteau sur sa victime c'était en 2018 à
joué-lès-tours la folie meurtrière en
réponse à une tentative d'abus sexuels
selon l'accusé le récit devant le palais
de justice de tours de théodore de
queiros il est 3h30 du matin lorsqu'une
dispute éclate entre mecs sans dion
jeune étudiant ivoirien et son hôte
bertrand louise et l'ivoirien de 22 ans
lui assène alors 28 coups de couteau
dont six mortels dans un appartement de
l'avenue victor hugo à joué-lès-tours le
cadavre et cachés sous un lit avant
d'être découvert cinq jours plus tard
par des invités après trois ans et demi
de détention provisoire l'étudiant
comparaître aujourd'hui pour homicide
volontaire devant la cour d'assises
d'indre et loire d'une petite voix
souvent trop faible pour être audible
l'accusé raconte son enfance difficile
en côte d'ivoire marquée par deux
guerres civiles sept élèves prometteurs
affiche est alors de briand d'ambition
ils voulaient découvrir le secret des
mathématiques décrivez son père selon
son avocate des proches de la victime se
sont constituées parties civiles pour
comprendre l'acte de cet étudiant au
casier judiciaire vierge je pense que
vraiment si ce port par si aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment pour comprendre pour
avoir des explications plus clair est ce
que ne peut faire un dossier papier j'ai
envie de dire et là c'est vraiment
d'entendre les déclarations de ce
monsieur sur son passage à l'acte
maixent du on reconnaît des problèmes
d'alcool liée à son arrivée à tours en
2017 mais il dénonce aussi des
agressions sexuelles commises par son
hôte aujourd'hui il semble prêt à
assumer ses responsabilités devant la
justice à quoi bon être défendus
répond-t-il à son avocate alors ils
l'attendaient avec une certaine
impatience de pouvoir s'expliquer
surtout pour les victimes d'ailleurs
parce qu'ils considèrent qu'il leur doit
la vérité leurs doigts et
d'essayer d'expliquer comment il en est
arrivé à cet acte le verdict est attendu
mercredi soir l'accusé encourt jusqu'à
30 ans de réclusion criminelle